perhaps one shouldn't be putting a date
stamp on these videos but since it's
early 2014 I'll say happy new year
everyone I'm absolutely delighted that
so many of you enjoyed so much the
previous video we put out which of
course was the great 202 jailbreak
what I want to do today is to carry on
that story given that you all seem to
enjoy it so much first of all to explain
how we in Nottingham got involved in the
whole 202 saga but then more importantly
to lead you on from that era to a time
only about two years after that when it
did become possible for everybody to do
their own typesetting so if we set the
time clock now back to about mid 1982
which is about just over two years after
the great jailbreak saga we in
Nottingham I heard all about what Bell
Labs had done although we didn't know
about the jailbreak all that we knew was
that they were using a 202 time setter
and we wanted at the time to typeset our
own
mathematics papers and you might say
well why would you want to do that can't
you just do them on a typewriter well of
course the special symbols in maths
caused a problem they don't look good at
all sometimes the math symbols had to be
inked in by hand and we had an absolute
perfectionist in the math department
called George George beshte and he had
been brought up in Oxford University
near the Oxford University Press
and he wanted all our exam papers to
look like works of art produced by oh
you P this costs money
this cost serious money particularly
it's mathematics papers which were at
the time the bulk of what we wanted to
do it was costing the university in
1980s money eighteen thousand pounds a
year to send the typesetting to outside
firms because we didn't have our own
typesetter so wouldn't it make sense to
get one of our own well yes George was
very persuasive
next thing I knew I had a telephone call
from the university's registrar saying
would I lead the team to implement a
typesetter a suitable typesetter
attached to a computer running this
newfangled thing called unix because the
university had been assured that we
could type set our own papers and that
this would in the medium term save his
money so thus began the great adventure
whereas brian had a team of three i had
a team of six and we're talking about
late 1982 when we got started now those
of you who followed the previous video
and followed the links out to the backup
documentation may recall there's at the
very end of the Bell Labs 202 saga
Mergenthaler in the States had come to
Brian said look you know there's a new
generation of machinery coming along
what perhaps we really should have done
all along is pointed you towards our
brand-new Omnitech in Nottingham
we were visited by lanatech Paul which
was the UK arm of Bergen taller they
were very honest with us they told us
all about the bad boys at their labs who
had got into their 202 and hoped that we
weren't there to do anything similar
than that and said well you know what we
said to them at the end and would say to
you now is maybe you ought to go with
this this is the future it's the
Omnitech effectively what it was was a
high priced high-resolution laser
printer it was the right decision in
principle but the timing wasn't just
awful it was very early on in the
development cycle of laser printers and
being a typesetter manufacturer and not
just if you like a low-quality laser
printer manufacturer like Imogen or
Canon or whatever who were quite happy
with 300 dots per inch
300dpi with laser printers is pretty
straightforward to get to work
relatively speaking but lino type
Mergenthaler had standards they wanted
at least 700 dpi
well it was doable in the day but only
just
look at the quality of the of the
catalogue and pamphlet alone oh and a
keyboard with things to keep a proper
typeset person happy like thin spaces em
spaces stuff like that lino type were
intent that this should be a proper type
setter it was to be high resolution
reluctantly they had to agree that the
972 DPI of the 202 which of course
involved smelly develop a bromide and
all that well if you move to paper
you're not gonna be able to do 900 DPI
but they did think they'd found a way to
do 720 dpi and yes they had but there
were problems at its very best when it
was working it could produce very
pleasing looking output but the trouble
with trying to do 720 dpi is that you
need very finely divided and suspended
toner inks in liquid also special zinc
oxide coated paper everything was fine
when it worked well in fact I've got
some samples here of the kind of output
quality you could get but woe betide you
if you ever skimped on cleaning the
thing every night and every morning
because what would happen was that the
finely divided toner ink would then clog
up the tubes that fed the imaging drum
at best it might blow a fuse and then if
you replace the fuse you'd find that
suddenly the pump would start splitting
a tube and pumping toner ink all over
the floor it really was a complete
nightmare and in fact it was not just us
the thing was actually was drawn I think
in early 1984 the other big problem with
it was that it was the future but it was
of course slow notice down here what
processes were being you
Intel 8080 zilog z80 and i think it's a
signet expressor the 8x 300 but we're
talking here essentially about the dawn
of 8-bit microchips they were the future
but they were not fast enough it very
soon became obvious that a faster 16-bit
system was the minimum that you needed
to run a machine like this so after
something like nine months of effort we
did succeed in typesetting the
mathematics papers for 1983 using the
Omnitech but we realized that we just
were not gonna be able to persist with
this into 1984 it was far too unreliable
so in a strange sort of reversal of
chronology we decided that what we'd
have to do and and Linotype UK supported
is fully in this decision was to go back
to generation and revert to using a good
old 202 which we knew the Bell Labs was
successfully used and yeah so we took
delivery of our Lanna type 202 Brian and
I had been in correspondence about the
fact that we were doing typesetting with
the Omnitech and it was arguably an even
bigger disaster than their 202 was it
was at that stage I think that Brian
sent me a copy of the vacation memo but
of course we both knew that there was no
way that we are not in them were going
to use the Bell Labs
software for start they couldn't and
wouldn't have supplied it to us and also
I think I felt by that time that the 202
have had four more years of development
work done on it I think the two two was
released in 1978
Brian's model of course was 1979 they
hadn't really had the time to fix all of
the hardware and software problems the
low-level liner type software to drive
the 202 was perfectly serviceable it was
called binary byte and that's what we
used in the early releases when Brian
was using it it was so full of bugs
it was unusable and that was why in the
jailbreak episode they
took over the entire machine hardware
and software cleared out all the liner
type software because they didn't think
it was reliable enough and when you face
also that the unreliability is in the
software were interacting with
unreliability is in the hardware you
could see why they went for a complete
replacement of everything but to learn
with such great credit the church who
was a great design and by the time it
did settle down
it gave us no trouble at all yes it was
a pain having to process bromide but
frankly we just sailed through 1984
typesetting burden with the 202 the only
sad thing for me as as a leader of the
team and if any of you want to know more
about the team we'll put a web link out
on this to the paper the web pointers
for those of you like that phrasing yeah
we'll put a web pointer a web link out
to the paper that describes the nautical
involvement you can find out the names
of all the people who helped me so much
at that time and I think you might at
the end of that get a feeling of
complete wistfulness that we had to give
this thing up there it was in our maths
basement being commissioned in late 1983
the typesetting season for exam papers
started typically in January February of
every year so by early 1984 it had to be
delivered out of our basement up the
hill as we call it to the exams
Department which was a subset of the
registrar's department and it was
installed there I sent two of my guys
Julian and William you'll see them
referred to in the cast list of this
paper and they looked after it
interfaced into UNIX and brought back
you know wistful reports to me of oh
when we were going to get one of our own
and so on in fact what the thing into
context I've got hold of here a
reproduction of our party piece that we
used to do for people on the 202 can you
imagine that in beautiful fresh gleaming
bromide what had happened was that
another colleague on the implementation
Douglas Douglas Woodall had been off to
a pure mathematics symposium I thinking
New Orleans or somewhere in the USA and
he came back he said I've just seen this
most wonderful wonderful wonderful
t-shirt and it's got Maxwell's equations
written out in full and this is what
this poster if you like is summarizing
those of you who are well up in
university level physics will know the
Maxwell's electromagnetic equations are
normally abbreviated using vector
operators called grab div and curl and
you can compress it all down into about
three lines this is what happens if you
expand those grads divs and curls out
into full-blown partial differential
notation so there we are our poster
we'll put a link out to that as well
lucky viewers and yeah it was wonderful
but when were we ever going to be able
to do that again for ourselves given
that our only hope had vanished up the
of the hill and that we for the next 18
months of typesetting winter if you like
had to revert back to this which is what
I've shown you before pretty good
quality dot matrix output but nothing to
compete with what would happen with
proper fonts and so on
you
in this era you mustn't imagine that the
202 and its characters were able to do
splines and arcs it's very clear this
difficulty with getting characters to
look good on a course resolution